and bring you some breaking news from
the Department of Health and Social Care
covering the United Kingdom Paul Kelso
is here with me Paul tell us about the
figures
yes well the the most striking number
here is that they've been a further 15
14 deaths forgive me since yesterday
from Kovac nineteen thirty-five patients
who've tested positive for the virus
have now died the Department of Health
says that's across the UK that's up from
21 yesterday yesterday we saw 10 extra
cases a doubling this is not quite a
doubling but is a substantial increase
it's the largest increase in the number
of deaths in any given day and it does
give us an indication of the way the
virus as many anticipate is going to
progress is that that steep curve we've
seen when looking at cases and the
outbreak in other countries particularly
in Italy that does now appear to be in
terms of death taking off in the UK the
first death was on the 5th of March and
it proceeded at around 1 or 2 fatalities
a day in very small steps in the last
two days we've seen 25 additional deaths
give you an idea of the overall testing
numbers forty thousand two hundred and
seventy nine people have been tested
overall thirty-eight thousand nine
hundred and seven of them negative and
one thousand three hundred and seventy
two positives those overall testing
figures and now very difficult to assess
because initially the tests were widely
across the community they're now only
being done in hospitals so these these
concluded tests that we're looking on
screen right now will be a mixture of
initially the ones that were done in and
out of hospital but in the last few days
we know that were only really counting
confirmed cases that have been
hospitalized exactly right so it's very
hard to know what kind of a consistent
isn't a consistent sample it would seem
now that the the overall testing numbers
are and I think sadly than in the coming
days and certainly all the indications
and the guidance that we've heard from
the chief medical officer and the chief
scientific officer and that the governor
is talking about at the moment is that
that the death total is going to be the
number that is the barometer sadly of
this outbreak
you